[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aimee P PA et baise son église et son
grand pardon
j'aime surtout la PAP
polaise qui
m'attend au pays
breton quittant ses jeunesses
àand quand le Breton devient
marin en allant au pêchees
d'Islande voici qu'el est le
dfin que le pauvre gars
fron tout
B
e
PE et sa
palaise son église et son grand pardon
j'aime surtout la FA
polaaise qui
m'attend au pays
breton le brave islandais sans
murmure lance la ligne ou
lepon puis dans un relant de son
mur il se couche dans
l'entrepont et le pauvre
gars
soupire tout
bas
je
serais bien mieux à mon aide devant un
joli feu
d'agent côté de ma fa poaise qui
m'attend au pays
breton mais souvent l'océan qu'il
donte se réveillant lâcheé cruelle et
lorsque le soir on se
compte bien des nom manqu à la peine et
le pauvre
gars
fronne
tout
bas
pour
servir la marine
française comme il faut plus d'un
moussaillon j'en causerai à ma
plaaise qui m'attend au
pays
bretan